marketing for the now the marketing for
the now marketing for the now marketing
for the now 10 minutes
12 remarkable guests for two hours
answering a singular important question
[Music]
are you ready gary
what do you think
gary gary gary it's time for the year i
can't believe it
i can't believe it either have you been
good good so we've got another
star-studded cast here we're gonna have
one question to wrap things up which is
what are your biggest challenges and
victories of 2021 and we're gonna kick
off with george felix he's the cmo of
tinder and he joined just about eight
months ago
and gary here's a little story that you
may not know about george
in kindergarten he crushed his grade
school talent show with his friends lip
syncing
everybody wants to rule the world by
tears and fear good song and apparently
it's the pleather jacket and the plastic
guitar that was just huge so just wanted
to kind of share that before we kick
things off welcome george
wow thanks uh thanks andre hey what's up
gary uh did not realize that i was gonna
make the cut
good news good news
well listen george we don't have a lot
of time so i'm going to get right into
it first of all happy holidays great to
see you
know a lot of people are excited in the
comments already because
tinder is one of the cultural
phenomenons of the last decade so a lot
of fans um you have an iconic cmo career
already and you're a youngster so i
think
it's really fun to get right to the
punch line
what
were your biggest challenges and
victories because i think you know i
think a lot about the yin and yang like
we talk about the black or white but
it's a gray it's kind that's why i'm
wearing gray it's a great day wins but
also losses how do you think back how do
you recap and create the context because
obviously you're new at tinder so
there's going to be different wins and
losses than some of our guests that are
coming up
yeah yeah you know when i came in uh
almost eight months ago
uh the challenge was really like you
know tinder has been this phenomenon
like you said for about you know nine
years
uh but
like the brands never really controlled
its own narrative never really known
exactly what it wants to be
um and the product has essentially been
the same for nine years so in terms of
challenges it was like hey i you know
coming in how do we define our brand
north star our positioning like what is
it what is our brand mission what do we
want it to be and so i'm excited i'll
i'll say like you know a victory for us
is we've just kind of started to to roll
that out but you know we as we look at
like what's going on in in the world and
the role tinder can play
for us uh our mission is to keep the
magic of human connection alive and so
you know in this world as technology
plays a bigger role in people's lives
it's it's kind of this weird paradox
that people are feeling more isolated
than ever and at our core what we do at
tinder is we bring people together and
so we think there's a big a big role to
play there and so i think that's just
being able to say that confidently and
and articulate that in a way that both
inspires our employees as well as our
members i think is a big victory for us
and then you know i think from a
challenge standpoint we've all been
dealing with it right the last couple of
years and uh particularly in our
category and so you know i think we've
had ups and downs um in terms of finding
ways that you know to help enable people
get through um this new world and the
pandemic that we've been going through
and still bringing people together and
uh and i think uh there have been times
when i think we've hit the mark and
we've been able to give people
experiences that that resonate and other
times where where we haven't quite hit
it and and you know we need to we need
to kind of pivot so
for us i think it's just about
continuing to experiment and learn and
try and listen to our our members about
what they what they need
as you think about 2022
you know obviously you've got your own
business strategies that you can't share
everything but is there anything you can
share
of ambitions for victories in
2022 yeah you know i think for you know
i mentioned it a little bit like uh from
uh from a product experience standpoint
uh we just like we haven't uh it's been
fairly one-dimensional if you think
about it like you know it's the core
experience nine years ago wasn't all
that different you get on your swiping
like in within minutes right and and
that's great and and that's always going
to be a core part of tinder but i think
what we want to do is we want to expand
and evolve and kind of make tinder more
three-dimensional and so um you know one
of the things we've just recently
launched is is called explore it's a
whole new piece of real estate on
uh on tinder and it's a new way to find
new connections and make and meet new
people where you can find a card stack
for gamers and binge watchers and
foodies and and you can do things by
interest we just did a partnership with
uh with spotify for something called
music mode so it's like you can have
your anthem going on like your walk-up
song um you know while you while you
browse through a profile but
as we look ahead you know we're going to
be partnering you know uh we want to you
can imagine we want to bring content
onto our platform we want to create more
engaging experiences how do we bring
gaming more more um you know
three-dimensional experiences into the
into the into what we do best which is
connect people and bring people together
how much of a
challenge is it
when
you've got this i mean the responses in
the comments on youtube and linkedin i
see all y'all uh
are quite positive to this concept of
elevating the connection point is it
challenging when a brand is known for
casual dating hooking up you know like
you know brands become what they become
we've seen refurbishment of brands in
society many times
um
we we're now getting to the place where
digital brands are going to start
because they're all so young we're going
to go through our those next 20 years
we're going to see
the tinders and the facebook is now meta
and like you know and can myspace ever
get rebooted like a fashion brand right
you're going to see these things
you came in with a lot of victories on
your resume you come into the challenge
of this job
how tell everybody who's listening how
hard it is to change the perception of
something once it's been accepted as
something
because it seems it seems to me and
obviously we work together in the vayner
world so i've got a little insight into
this but even what you're saying here
publicly it's obviously like oh tinder
is about to like widen itself out based
on what you were just saying
how hard is it to widen yourself that
you know amazon going from just selling
books to everything
that took a real process that a lot of
people don't remember i remember the
blog post saying stick to books
i lived it stick to wine wine guy why
are you talking about business and
technology
how hard is it
i mean it's it's definitely not
something that that happens you know
over you know the course of a couple
months right it's uh it's going to be
something we have to have a concerted
effort on and a big part of what we need
to do like we don't have an awareness
problem right everyone knows
and we're synonymous with with our
category for us it's you know we want to
be known for you know more and and we
want to change the way people think
about
uh think about tinder so we make the
largest investment in safety and trust
and products that make people feel safe
when they're using our product do we get
credit for that probably not we need to
do a better job of changing perception
and telling telling more of those
stories
you know the way that people use our our
product yes you know it can be anything
from a fleeting thing a hookup all the
way through a long-lasting romance
through friendships and we're here for
that and frankly that's being dictated
by gen z right there yes it's also
dictated by the consumer like i love
when people are like i had a combo with
somebody about a different app once and
i was like well people use instagram dm
for casual dating and that's not that
wasn't the early purpose of like
humans are gonna do human [ __ ]
regardless of what apps or technology
tries to do totally totally and like i i
you know i spent a couple hours a week
talking to college students just
learning about their lives like they
didn't use the word dating you know like
it's it's it's all about like how they
want to use the platform and so we need
to adapt to that and we need to be there
for all those scenarios that they want
to and so that's what we're trying to do
and you know that that is going to take
time right it's going to it's going to
take people we're like we're going to
people are going to have to realize oh
there's something new at tinder there's
more to tinder than i thought and we
know that you know we're in it for the
long haul and that's gonna take you know
not months but probably you know over
the course of years we're gonna we're
gonna continue to evolve and we're gonna
have to prove it through the product
experience
uh that you know that we can provide
talk now elevated you have a lot of cmo
friends so let's talk about the industry
less than tinder what do you think are
the biggest opportunities for victories
for brands in general
in 2022
uh from an innovation place like when
you know one thing i've always liked
from watching ufr now i'm getting a
chance to see it up close a little bit
more is
consumer common sense is what i would
call it i think you've got that in your
arsenal which is why you've had success
if you're talking to 500 cmos right now
and you're making a blanket same because
some are there some haven't even started
give me the george's one or two things
that all of us
could get a lot more upside in building
our brands if we lean into x
yeah i mean to me i've always been a
pretty simple simple person trying to
keep it keep it basic like to me it is
uh really listening listening to your
consumers and trying to get in there and
understand what they're what they're
doing and what they're telling us right
now is like
they want uh you know like you said
they don't want to be told how to do
something or they want to be put into
like a box say this is the only way to
do it they want to be able to come to an
experience and really define it and
shape it and be able to
change the way they want to use it and
and maybe that's using it using tinder
in one way on one day and then coming
back three days later and using it in a
different way and so
for me it's you know in working with our
product team how do we make a product
that is flexible enough fluid enough
where you know people can use and
experience it in different ways and
really dictate that and not be forced uh
into kind of like just what we think we
want them to do
in terms of in terms of using the
product what about what about tactically
do you see
media spend or creative like just
because i know so many marketers watch
this any thoughts on the evolution of
media and creative spends and where they
go distribution or types of creative
oh i mean i think just like the uh in
terms of like i think the days of like
the bigger you know like
huge spends on production and in big
swings and doing like the big you know
yeah the big anthemic tvc and like the
big you know you're gonna have your two
campaigns a year i think those days are
done i'm definitely like uh adapting
learning more um just in in some of the
shifts i've made from brands over the
years you know from you know nine ten
years ago on old spice the way we
thought about things
at the time yeah now thinking through
it's much more quicker quicker hitting
content how many pieces of content can
you create quickly um you know we've
been talking a lot about you know when
you're doing um when you're when you're
making a you know a big a a big campaign
these days it's more about like what are
all the different places it can go and
true before i let before i let you go in
two minutes so many questions of would
tinder ever allow us to meet each other
on the metaverse you know i think uh
obviously this has been the year of the
nft i've been at the center of it i've
been less about the vr
metaverse because i think it's a little
further away than people realize but
any thoughts of like do you say do you
see a day in age where people are having
dates at a bar in the metabours
yeah i mean i i think it's i think it's
possible i mean for for sure like
you know in in the world of tinder where
we're still you know the majority people
are about in real life connections at
some point
but you know we we have to continue to
look to see where people want to go and
if if that's where um the world's headed
then tinder is going to be looking into
it and so i can't say we have you know
concrete plans for the metaverse right
now but uh we're certainly monitoring it
and checking it out and we want to be
wherever people however people want to
meet and however people want to connect
going to the future you can expect
tinder to be there
um any parting thoughts of inspiration
for all the youngsters that want to see
a lot of people wanting to have your job
one day what is the 15 to 25 year old or
the 33 year old that wants to get out of
finance or legal or something and aspire
to be a cmo one day any any words of
wisdom as we get out of here
um i would say uh
just get like being comfortable being
uncomfortable uh for me is a big one so
like
take take swings take chances keep keep
learning new things and uh that's been
kind of how i've tried to make the
decisions i've made
along the way in my career
continued success my friend happy
holidays thank you for being here gary
thank you cheers
thanks george and thanks gary
now we're gonna have a little throwback
thursday moment dustin is going to take
us back to july 4th
good afternoon
in less than a week we hope to fire up
our grills
and launch one of the biggest fourth of
july celebrations in the history of the
united states
the united states
those words have new meaning for us all
today
and whether you drive a pickup or a
hybrid you live in the heartland or on
the coast
or whether you pronounce it america or
america
we're all americans
sell them on the same page
but reading from the same book
on holidays anyway
perhaps it's fate that this fourth of
july
we gotta once again come together to
lend a hand to those less fortunate
whose fate still lies in the balance
we're fighting for freedom for all
not from alien invaders
from separation
from being cooped up while baking bread
and ignoring basic hygiene
the time has come for us
to get fresh
gather the crew
and eat veggie and meat burgers till we
sweat
and then
let's work together towards a future
where everyone can come to the party
and should we win the day
the fourth of july will no longer be
known as an american holiday
but it's the day when the world declared
in one voice we will not go quietly into
the night we will fill the sky with so
much light and freedom this thing will
rue the day had ever messed with us
together
we celebrate
our independence day
[Applause]
[Music]
go forth america
next up we welcome rob lenoi our the
beloved chief creative officer of
vaynermedia
the
bill pullman
guys
great to see that piece again and so
great to see you again bill how are you
my friend
very good very good good that we could
circle back at the end of the year that
was the middle of the year when we spent
so much time together that was the goal
that was the goal really really fired up
to have you join us for this
conversation i have to share with you
that folks around the agency are are
calling us the great hollywood madison
avenue bromance so i just thought i'd
kick it off with that um a little bit of
background on the show bill this is
really oh it tells it like it is and i
know from you know your our
conversations first and foremost but
also from your career that you're one
hell of a straight shooter so hopefully
in our chat today we got about 10
minutes with each other we can inspire
our listeners to really do some cool
[ __ ] um right now what i'm seeing and
what what all marketers are frankly
seeing is we're all struggling to be
relevant to really connect and engage
with audiences in real ways
and this is something that i've started
to call it's probably nothing new but
it's what i like to frame it as having
real creative conviction
um when we did this piece
um during covet it was so important to
get this piece right
um or it just would have been a disaster
and i personally learned so much from
working with you
so maybe we can kick this off if you
could share with the audience when you
saw this script and i know you've
probably seen a million
uh prior to this script people that
wanted you to you know bring back this
this famous script um what did you see
in it
that said to you i can land this this is
the this is something that i can see
really connecting um with people on and
having real impact maybe just give us a
little peek in your mind as you kind of
saw the script for the first time
well
do i call you bro or bromance you can
call me whatever you want bill well i
mean some of it is just i was in the
middle of shooting in in canada and a
heavy production load when this uh
call came in from my
my
rep saying you you know there's
budweiser wants to do a campaign
using the speech for
uh you know
a budweiser commercial yeah and i said
are you freaking kidding me here we go
terrible
yeah the worst idea acrolege holy cow
we're gonna do a commercial and i'm
gonna get a salary for using this speech
that was so important to so many people
and now and we're just selling something
and uh
and at this point
let me just look at the text
oh god and then something
i realized there's somebody back there
writing this text
that has an idea
about how to kind of make fun of
yourself and make a little twinkle in
the eye about the whole thing but put it
to some purpose
and right now he's selling
a beer but
maybe this same person who wrote this
with this little idea might and then i
went nah i don't have any time to talk
to anybody i can't do it can't do it
yeah and then my managers just said look
i
before we all say goodbye we don't want
anything to do with this what would be
the conditions you might want to do and
i thought this was him
coming up with an idea but i think that
this is the same person who wrote that
text he's a
a sly little guy that's coming in here
and saying what does it take i'm willing
to listen and i'm willing to do whatever
it takes
and i was
hooked and then we got it i said okay
let me talk to this guy
and so i think that's why now in
december in the middle of everything
else i wanted to circle back with you
because it was two people meeting each
other through content and what exact
take that was and man we i i we had some
tough
tough you know it was off the table on
the table
i want to talk about that a little bit
because
we yes we connected over the content but
you and i went toe to toe like a couple
times um let's talk about the time where
you had a vision we landed on the vision
together right we added the charitable
component to it and then i had to kind
of my do my job and kind of tighten your
words and make it fit a certain kind of
rigor and you were like no [ __ ] way
rob talk a little bit about that and i
was so happy that you did stand your
ground there because ultimately what
came out was a truly authentic piece
that you believed in but maybe let's
talk about that the time when you pop me
in the keister
well you know i i was not in a frame my
normal affable self was at a low low
level because i was so freaking tired
working and then to imagine coming in
and doing this thing on a weekend and
having to travel to halifax in order to
shoot it and have everybody become i
just thought this is this has got to be
real it's got to be real and there we
were the fourth of july now now think
back you know the message was hey it's
the fourth of july we're we're all beat
this covid 19 thing let's have a party
yeah wow i'm glad that didn't go out
you know that would have been we would
have had our pants down but i you know
because just as we were starting to talk
about it india and brazil the numbers
were surging and look they're still
searching you know and we are this
message of this thing had to be not just
of this moment of this year but they had
to be real about what it is to really
kind of connect to the idea of an event
today which is we're we're no longer
just one country we are part of a global
and effort and we have to take we
let's welcome and when we came on that
phrase let's welcome everybody to the
party is still the thing that i thought
resonated in watching it again and i i
think that thing is what we
i think there was a lot of politics
involved in it which i don't know how
uh often this happens for you but for me
i was seeing every cut that was made in
a political
i saw its political context which is hey
we don't we don't want to make you know
we don't want to
actually you know we're not even sure
about international people let's just
have it be a party that we got to pull
together and you know not worry about in
the whole point was international thing
and so you know i could feel that there
was just a lot of sensitivities and
political correctness that was gonna get
involved but i think one you uh
and and every time
you know
i just listening to um
you know gary and and the conversation
with george up about you know media guys
talk at a different speed than i speak
you're giving this extra time it's all
good listen to that
one holy cheese these guys are like rat
attack machine guns just
how do you get victory
and i just my brain doesn't process that
way you know so i found in our talking
you know we had to be real with each
other if we felt there was [ __ ]
coming in you know or anybody was trying
to slip slip you in some direction
without you quite knowing what was going
on we had to say no no no what's going
on here and i love that you
always would you just would say reset
let's reset and is what can we say and
we're basically
you know i had you over the barrel
because i knew there wasn't another bill
pullman that was gonna come in and take
a job and and don't think they didn't
ask at one point they were like can
someone else do this i'm like no
it's gotta be bill listen i i always
i've often said like good work
it doesn't just happen it's hard work
right and i think the the partnership
that you and i had the creative
conviction we had the back and forth we
had the vigilance that was required
right had one of us taking our eye off
the ball if anyone for that matter had
taken our their eye off the ball the
director the others it wouldn't have had
landed the way it landed because it
landed the way we both wanted it to land
and that that's what was so
important for me and i know for you and
i think that that was really the glue
that sent it on its way i i read
the constitution though i mean rob you
know you had me and one end
and then you had the
the client you know budweiser which i
didn't really even know very much about
that end of it but i'm sure you were
getting all kinds of sometimes we were
on the phone at the same time it was
just like one no no no no it was great
though but i i so value
our partnership on this and what we
created it was wonderful and it there
were a couple things on social media
that stood out i know we wanted global
and you know biden got involved and it
got really really big but there was
there was a tweet that really resonated
i thought was amazing and just said
i can't believe
it took a beer
and bill pullman to bring this country
together again but it looks like that's
exactly what they did and i just thought
that that was just such a great
summation
of what we put out there if we have a
second i think there was a really really
wonderful anecdote we talked about
throwback but this is like a throwback
to a throwback because we went back to
the speech for july 4th but obviously 25
years ago you you delivered that
absolutely world famous epic speech that
i know that you were involved in making
that as well right um but there was a
there was a fellow on set right you told
me a story
about i think it was the dp who saw
independence day was inspired and then
was actually on our set there was
something absolutely magical do you
remember that oh yeah yeah it was uh you
know i've been working for four years on
this um
the center and that the
director of photography radium chung uh
he had
just come
to this country america when
independence day was coming out and he
was in here for i think it was three
weeks and he was just meeting new people
and he was just barely here just got
here had no nothing
and they said let's go out to see this
movie independence day
and he wanted so badly to go with them
all but he didn't have the money for the
ticket
he just said i just can't i made up an
excuse and so
after we finished shooting on that
saturday where we had to take everybody
from our our you know from shooting in
production in an hour and a half south
of there we had to bring him on saturday
we only had so much time and that's a
whole nother story which is barely a lot
of urgency but we made it and we made it
through and then he came up and he said
to me in the trailer he said you know
bill i just want you to know this story
which he said and for me now to be able
to come back full circle and be the dp
on set for
this uh
this commercial which this attempt to
bring everybody together
our kind of a revision of it all was
so meaningful to him uh absolutely
fantastic collateral bill i thank you so
much obviously we will stay in touch
into the future i love our partnership
and i hope that honestly we can do
something again in the future and kind
of pretty sure we're gonna
great same here great seeing you bill
and happy happy holidays and again
congratulations on the new grandson
thanks so much rob
that was amazing thanks to you both
next up we welcome ryan harwood he's the
ceo of our gallery media group and he's
going to be the host for the rest of the
show hey ryan how's it going good how
are you we are good super fired up to
have marissa jarrett on next she's the
svp and cmo for 7-eleven there she is
hey guys he's definitely mixing it up
with her team so i'm excited to hear a
little bit more take it away you guys
you're right
how are you i'm great how are you doing
good good good it's going to be a tough
act to follow mr president there right i
know
a lone star in the house i love it
all right we have the last marketing for
the now of the year here so i am pumped
up to uh to run through this with you
you know as we as we say goodbye to 2021
and hello to 2022 i'm super curious as
the cmo of 7-eleven what have been your
biggest challenges and victories over
the last year
yeah
i mean the biggest challenges are
keeping up with the changing demands and
behaviors of the consumer
full stop
and we saw that hit a next level last
year when covid came on and it's just
continued honestly over the course of
the past 20 months and so that really
keeps me as a marketer on my toes my
entire team and frankly our whole
company um and we've turned that into a
victory i would tell you um similar
actually to what george talked about at
tinder we've gotten really clear on our
brand purpose and understanding what is
the role that the 7-eleven brand plays
in the lives of our customers and then
how do we really dial into that every
single day with every single action that
we take
so we um we've spent some time
doing brand purpose work we actually
call our brand purpose activate awesome
and it serves as sort of a clarion call
for everything that we do in marketing
and really across the organization how
are we activating awesome and our
customers and our associates and our
franchisees and our communities
and and making sure that we live you
know we do right by that
that's awesome
as a chief marketing officer for a lot
of folks that are listening that aspire
to be cmos in their careers i'm curious
what do you think are your most
important skills that have gotten to you
to where you are today
yeah it's a common question and i would
tell you i didn't start my career in
marketing i started off in finance
and i i worked in the corporate finance
arena for several years and
realized like yes i can do this but it's
not really what motivates me and so
i switched careers and moved into
marketing and i'm actually very thankful
that i have that experience in finance
because i think that's the secret to a
strong marketer is one who can operate
with a right and a left brand approach
one who understands the business and how
to drive the business and how to measure
the impact of marketing on the business
and one who can think creatively and
understand the consumer and really
act in an empathetic way and and you
know and kind of unlock those solutions
that aren't necessarily rational to the
rational side of the brain so i think
that's the secret for marketing and for
marketers is to have both of those skill
sets and be able to use them
um together
yeah it's funny you say that because
you know i always pigeonholed myself
early in my career as a business person
because i started in finance too i
worked there for a long time and
as each year has passed i find myself to
be more and more of a creative and less
on the business side enjoying what i do
for a living so it's fascinating we have
a similar background from that
perspective
um i'm curious when you're hiring
and
you know there's a lot of folks on the
call that that want to be hired that
want to get jobs at all these different
organizations
what makes an outstanding employee at
your organization specifically what do
you look for when you're hiring yeah
i mean i always look for intellectual
curiosity and passion for the brand
right i want to work with someone who's
curious about the world and about our
consumer and about the brand and about
culture and about how we can be a bigger
part of that right
so intellectual curiosity passion for
the brand is first
the ability for someone to operate
vertically and horizontally is critical
in today's day and age we're looking for
subject matter experts across the realm
of marketing whether that's insights or
advertising and media
data analytics but that's not enough you
also have to have a systems mindset and
understand kind of how the whole
business works and what your role
contributes to so that kind of vertical
horizontal mindset
and then lastly i would say gosh just
this drive for results and a bias for
action we're a retailer we move fast so
you got to be comfortable with that kind
of pace and really enjoy it and thrive
in it so those are the three areas we
look for
totally
you know if you were leading a keynote
at your alma mater
what would you want to leave behind what
would you want to teach or share those
aspiring marketing students what's the
message yeah
i am well i love what george said about
getting comfortable feeling
uncomfortable i think that's right on i
think in addition to that i would
encourage uh students today to get
comfortable taking risks
you can't plan every single thing out
and so sometimes when unexpected
opportunities
even though they may not look like an
opportunity present themselves to you
how do you like lean in and really take
every opportunity as a way to grow and
learn and make an impact and over time
you'll find that that really helps helps
build your career helps build you as a
person
as a you know parent mother sister
daughter friend etc and i think ryan
probably our shared experience and
finance is a good example of that it's
like you know we could just as easily
say like that was an epic fail working
in finance for a couple of years but
actually it was a wonderful thing that
happened right so how do you lean in and
take risks in the spirit of of having a
growth mindset
i love that
i know this goes so so quickly it always
it goes way too quickly so i'm gonna
skip right to the rapid fire questions
here ready special speed round so let's
get to numbers
tell me 80s or 90s music 80s all the way
salty or sweet
both all the way
beach or mountains
are you a morning or night person
morning
europe or asia vacation
both all the way
and of course because of 7-eleven cherry
or blue raspberry slurpee what are you
going for i can't choose that's like
picking your favorite kid gosh
depends on the day and the time of day
probably
thank you so much for joining us marissa
we really really appreciate it thank you
ryan happy holidays see ya
that was so good we've never had anyone
say both to so much it says
yeah right
i love it
happy holidays thanks for joining us
happy holidays see you guys
ryan next up we've got anisha ragavan
and she's the cmo of number seven beauty
company north america for walgreens
boots alliance and she oversees the
whole portfolio of beauty brands but one
thing you may not know about her is the
mo her life's motto which is a smile is
understood in any language just love
that
i like that too
that's in my high school yearbook
i love that and you have such a lovely
smile i understand why you say that
thanks ryan
anisha thank you for joining me today
i'm excited to have you on we've
obviously known each other a very long
time and i've loved watching your career
over the years and all you've
accomplished so i am psyched to jump in
here and learn a little bit more about
you yes thanks for having me
absolutely so tell me what were your
biggest challenges and victories in 2021
over the last year
yeah um biggest victory was
um
bringing helping 10 000 women get back
to the workforce so
we
one of my biggest brands is number seven
it was founded in the 1930s in england
by a woman who was all about female
empowerment so she was the you know in a
time where brands were putting women and
ads in skirts as housewives she was
portraying them in pants as working
women and she employed women and
educated them she did all these things
for female empowerment so it's been in
our dna for 86 years and towards the end
of 2020 we were watching the labor spots
and
women were leaving the workforce at four
times the rate of men um it was you know
five million women at that point had
left the workforce in 2020 and so
as a brand that really you know our
purpose is all about female empowerment
we wanted to do something about that so
we launched at the beginning of 2020 a
platform called unstoppable together our
brand purpose platform in the us for the
first time
and we uh supported women in their
journey back to work so we did things
like launching the biggest job summit of
its kind we had resources for women to
get back uh you know small group
coaching and things like that
and so it was um an incredible victory
on so many levels i mean a just being
able to imp impact that many women's
lives was incredible but then also
from a team standpoint like we just
really came together and um it's a
source of pride you know we built
something in 10 weeks soup to nuts and
uh and just
built the plane while we were flying it
and for the brand we had our second
largest
volume of google searches in our brand
history and then for me personally i am
incredibly passionate about gender and
gender equality and to be able to live
out that passion that work was
incredible so that was the biggest
victory
and then the biggest challenge was the
great resignation so you know everyone
in corporate america is facing this in
the last six seven months
the um turnover rates have been their
all-time high in the last 10 years and
my team didn't escape from that so you
know i have a large team and within
those teams some of those teams were
facing as much as 50 attrition at any
given point
and so you can imagine like resource
planning recruiting
strategies like reward incentives you
have to rethink everything but also
while you're keeping the business going
you have to support the team on the
ground and so i had people leaving for
all kinds of reasons you know some of
them were relocating reassessing their
lives some of them were burnt out but i
also had people who had lost a parent to
covid or
um you know relative to suicide like
really incredibly difficult life
circumstances
and
supporting your team through those
things up until the point where they
decide to leave is an incredible
challenge
and you have to put people first you
know at that point
and health first um
but also on the other end of the
spectrum the people who didn't leave
now there's all these holes in the team
how do you support them because it's
it's natural tendency in corporate
america especially if there's an
overachiever to pile on more work but
just because someone carries the load
well does not mean it's not heavy you
know so you've gotta again keep the
business going while protecting those
team members so that was probably the
biggest challenge
wow
that must have been super challenging to
do
yeah
you know and tell me as someone that's
part of the the c-suite team you know
how do you think we could all be
better leaders going into 2022 what have
we learned and how can we all be better
yeah i love this question
and if you look at leadership not as a
title but as an honor that's you know
that
is bestowed upon us by the people
willing to follow us
then i think leadership comes down to
trust and self-awareness and i had this
incredible professor in business school
francis frye
who would talk about the concept of
leadership based on trust
and she always said that trust is based
on three things
based on authenticity so if you're my
leader
do i believe that the person i'm seeing
is really who you are
it's based on um
logic so can i trust your decisions and
the logic behind them and it's based on
empathy do i believe that you're in it
for me as much as for yourself
and what she said was
when you're stressed out
one of those things will wobble
everybody has a wobble
and so you have to be self-aware of what
that wobble is in order to get the right
cane for those moments where you're
stressed and so i just thought that was
incredibly brilliant and i've always
thought about what's my wobble and how
do i fix that you know and i think if
everybody knew their wobble when they're
stressed out
they'd be better leaders
interesting wobble i'm gonna take that i
like it
you know and as a marketer how do you
think we can continue to dial the impact
we're making up as marketers just in
general
yeah um
so you know there's so much going on in
consumers lives right now in all of our
lives at a macro level obviously the
last two years has been
you know very different and very um
stressful in lots of different ways and
so
it's it's one of the original marketing
mantras that you have to meet a consumer
inside their lives and
make it valuable and easy for them and
there's lots of different ways to do
that so i'll give a few examples um i
saw a brand recently doing audio
advertising and they use voice
activation to offer samples so a
consumer you know on spotify listening
to something this ad comes on but they
can use alexa to say hey i want a sample
and it shows up at their door right
super easy super valuable
another example is we're working on our
next big innovation i can't tell you
what it is but what i can tell you is
we are co-creating it with a thousand
women and so those thousand women from
beginning to end have been
really helping shape everything so the
concept of the innovation
the packaging the product formula is now
the advertising
and so we are meticulously designing it
for their lives
and then a third example i'm sure you
saw like the whole world the peloton
like incredible talk about like agility
in marketing in order to fit into what's
what's happening in a consumer's life
right in a cultural moment
and that team had to respond to what was
going on on sex in the city right their
livelihood depended on it
and they did they built that out in 48
hours and used this concept i love of
fast fertizing which i know you know you
guys run an incredible company you know
well
the ability to create really great
advertising really fast and marry that
with tech driven media buying like that
kind of agility is the future and um is
absolutely necessary to making a bigger
impact in marketing
totally the first the two things i heard
you say there was a eliminate friction
from the process with that spot by
example the more you can eliminate
friction closer you are to the consumer
the more likely you convert but also b
speed speed matters
right speed of ideation speed of
exercise
if you want to be part of the important
conversations and culture like you
that's just that's rule number one speed
happens
yep because because relevance is
consideration is driven by relevance and
in order to be relevant you need speed
so it makes a lot of sense
um i'm going to throw an interesting one
of you here drive yourself one word
describe myself in one word um
i'd say genuine oh you know what no i'm
gonna i'm gonna make up a word
opt a realist i tell my boss all the
time i am optimistic and realistic at
the same time that combination of being
able to like
you know dream big but also know reality
um i think is one of my sweet spots
you know we call that because that that
is a big quality we look for we call
that practical optimism in the company
here
that was real words though so i have to
make up a word you're right you're right
you're right
all right we're jumping to the speed
rounds let's get to know anisha okay
all right tell me salty or sweet
salty europe or asia vacation
oh i love both asia
italian or sushi
yeah i'm vegetarian but i'll still pick
sushi them avocados i
almond milk or oat milk
almond
are you a morning or night person
total night owl
me too
beach or mountains um both equally
anisha thank you so much for joining us
goes way too quick i look forward to
seeing you in the new year
same thanks so much ryan take care happy
holidays
that was so good i think we're going to
have to include a what's your wobble
going forward let's throw that in there
ryan such a big
francis fry man thanks for reminding me
that was really really good love it love
it all right we got one more ryan mandy
rossi she's the vp and president of
marketing for kroger
and boy does she run everything there
it's a 120 billion dollar business that
spans 22 retail banners and more than 2
800 physical stores and a huge
e-commerce platform
i'll let you guys take it from here
i love it hi
hi ryan how are you
good how's it going great great
i am so excited to have mandy on i've
had the privilege of working closely
with mandy over the last year during
quarantine and covet et cetera so i have
a lot of context and i'm thrilled that
you're on here so thank you for joining
us yeah thanks for having me and thanks
for the partnership it's been uh
fabulous working with you guys
thank you
so let's talk you know as we say goodbye
to 21 and we head into 22 what have we
learned like how can we look back and be
smarter as we move forward and what were
some of the challenges and victories
that you've experienced
yeah well so first on learning maybe
start there um
i think in a positive way on 21 one
thing
i feel like i've learned is people are
endlessly resilient
and creative and will find a way
um maybe the other learning is is
there's no solid ground anymore
anywhere
so even when you think maybe it's going
to shape up this way the curveballs will
keep coming um but i will say even
looking at our industry looking at my
team looking at the business
even as curveballs keep coming and a
year ago we would never have imagined we
would still be in this pandemic and the
way we are but people just keep finding
a way and as the customer moves which is
also happening endlessly um you know
it's been really inspiring to see how
creativity continues to show up to find
new ways to help people get done
whatever it is they're trying to do
in terms of victories i mean we have the
luxury of being in the food space which
is super fun um and is very integrated
into people's day in day out lives um
and we're big right so we serve 60
million customers a year
and it's been
really kind of a special place to be
in the context of everything else that's
going around because food is so central
to culture
and when you're in a pandemic obviously
the way people were eating and cooking
and shopping evolved really rapidly and
then continued to evolve and then you
would see like oh a little shift happens
here and then maybe we go back
um in regard to like food at home and
cooking which at one point was fun then
it became a grind
and i think for my team one thing i'm
most proud of is the way we've been able
to help people really eat the way they
want to eat through this so our brand
promise is to make the best of food
accessible to all our campaign is fresh
for everyone um and that accessibility
has been sort of a thread throughout the
pandemic and i think in 21 we found some
fun ways in some pretty meaningful ways
whether that's our e-commerce businesses
scaled rapidly like most businesses who
have e-commerce um but things like we
opened in florida for the first time
that's a market we've never served and
we do it with warehouses that are run by
robots with then wonderful delivery
drivers who bring you your groceries in
a refrigerated truck we've never done
that before and we've figured it out and
launched the brand in a different way
where we're only a pure play e-commerce
retailer um so we're continuing to find
those new and different ways to see
where is the customer going and then how
do we find not just a marketing message
but really pull the brand through to the
experience to create meaningful
solutions um you know for whatever their
need is whether it's an enduring need or
something that's maybe
a need that's showing up in a way it
hasn't before totally
you're in such a fascinating industry
because there's so much um
traditional stuff that goes on yet you
need to move into the news so kind of
like being as a food retailer how do you
hold on to the old like things like
grocery coupons but also moving to the
new like the ecom you're talking about
in online shopping how do you think
about that
yeah that i will say that is one of the
challenges we sometimes face is we are
living
a little bit of a foot in historically
what's work and then a foot in modern
marketing and where we want to go we are
blessed with a tremendous data asset um
which helps us in in the sense of
modernizing and personalization and
media and all of that
but we also still have 2800 stores with
cardboard signs all over them right um
i would say the way we start one always
starting with the customer and even
looking at the old stuff and making sure
we're not on autopilot like are we just
doing that because we've always done it
like should we be doing as many signs as
we are should we be doing coupons in the
way that we've done them and sometimes
the answer is like actually yeah the
customer still really likes that there's
high engagement with it it's creating
value for them so it makes sense to keep
doing
sometimes though it's like well actually
maybe that isn't as relevant as it used
to be and so we need to then look at
things in a new way whether it's
reimagining the way that job gets done
or it's just like people aren't engaging
let's say with media in that way so we
need to move to something new
um
you know i will say measurement is the
other thing we
again are blessed with um a lot of
closed loop measurement because we have
a good first party data asset
and we have good media partners as well
but sometimes to make sure we have
the measurement of what's going on so we
know we're investing in the right places
we're investing where the customer is
but then trying to carve off
intentionally innovation where it's like
we don't know exactly how this is going
to work but we're just going to go do it
because we've never done it before so we
have no data to know
and i think that's the piece where we're
continuing to
look for talent and push ourselves to be
brave and trying the new even if we have
no idea how it's going to work out
and the good news again with the scale
we have is we might not do that in every
single market all the time or we might
not do it with every audience but how
can we take a piece of something
roll up our sleeves and start learning
on it and then once we figure it out be
ready to go at a bigger scale
yeah we have a comment in the chat from
someone named alex rivas you know shout
out to him for saying nft coupons that's
how you go
all right we're taking that one thank
you thank you
um you know you you mentioned a big
challenge before for you is finding ecom
talent like why is this such an
important focus for kroger moving into
22.
so our our business strategy is win with
fresh
and accelerate with digital
for us to meet the growth goals that we
have with where the customer is going
e-commerce is the future and it's not
just the future it is today um you know
we are our e-commerce business basically
doubled nearly overnight in the pandemic
and we're working to double that again
in the next 18 months or so
um and if we look at it it allows us to
do a few things right so we can serve
people more completely in the markets
we're already in it also allows us to
get into new markets which especially
for how established we are new market
growth is a critical pillar to us
growing um you know the talent piece is
key because it is different and i will
say the challenge we find
maybe even different than if we were
like a small econ player is we need
people
who can think and actually you guys were
chatting about this earlier
horizontally so be able to see
okay e-commerce fits here but really a
customer is engaging with us outside of
let's say florida where we're only ecom
they're engaging with us in a
multi-dimensional way where today they
may pop in the store tomorrow they may
place a pickup order maybe need it
delivered tonight
and so we really need talent that is not
only really good at some of the blocking
and tackling of performance marketing
and e-commerce how maybe traditionally
we sometimes think of it but who can
also think about
a bigger like we're bringing the brand
to life across all of these touch points
e-commerce is a critical role but it's
not the only role and the pieces need to
connect um it's a little bit of a
unicorn to find um i mean obviously
everybody's looking for ecommerce talent
so there is just a war for e-commerce
talent but then also to find e-commerce
people who can really
navigate with the breadth and scale that
that is um has been particularly a
challenge so if you are all out there
listening please hit me up we are
definitely looking
for folks with those skill sets there
you go a recruiting call out head up
mandy
um you know i'm curious as a sea chief
marketing officer what do you think
are your most important skills that got
to you to where you are today and that
allow you to be good at your job
um i mean probably a few basic things so
i did not even start my career in
marketing i started in analytics and
consumer strategy
and i think what has actually served me
well is that having that mindset of
really being curious about people and
systems and culture and like why is this
happening and where might it go what
could the scenarios in the future be
um has helped me as i've come into more
of a marketing leadership role to have
that grounding and frankly it is very
helpful in today's world to be pretty
analytically savvy as a marketing leader
because that melding of analytics and
creativity is so critical
um
i would also say just um
leading a team and i was blessed i
started my career at procter gamble i
had so many wonderful people who
built into me and taught me about how do
you lead a team how do you set a
strategy
and i think that has helped me a lot to
understand
one how
to create clarity but then know when to
get out of the way and let the team do
what they do and and i think that's
a big piece of my job now is listening
more than talking
especially as we're talking about things
that might be new mediums or new
technologies
almost 100 of the time there is someone
on my team who knows it better than i do
at the start
and my job is to frankly like flow
resources to the right place see where
there's an opportunity place a bet on
something where someone is passionate
about it um and then encourage the
talent so that they grow um
so
those are probably some you know and
then there's just the role we need to do
in the company of advocating for the
consumer advocating for the role of the
brand and guiding the overarching um
sort of choices as we look at the
products which in our case could be
store experiences side experiences
things like that
love it and you know how are you moving
in general kroger to a more agile
marketing approach and i remember you
mentioned in 2020 it was just about
keeping your head above water and then
in 2021 you've been strategizing like
what's for 2022 how are you going to try
to move to that more agile marketing
approach
yeah so a few things so we are changing
sort of our annual operating model so um
we work in okrs for who those who are
familiar with that
um i'm very excited to move to that um
we also talk about agile with a capital
a because i think sometimes people use
agile like we're going to be agile as in
like we're not going to make a decision
we're just going to constantly change
and react which is the opposite of what
agile should be
um so we've really focused on setting
very clear north stars on like four or
five things
that are the north stars for the whole
organization and then through
an annual planning process and then
quarterly and even monthly and weekly
check-ins to calibrate along the way we
empower the teams to figure out how they
get there and i think that's the piece
that will allow us to be more agile is
frankly pushing that accountability down
so that we don't have like we're a big
corporation you can easily get bogged
down on like layers and layers of
approvals and input and everybody senior
wants to see everything we are really
trying to say like our job as senior
leaders is to set the high level roadmap
and then we let the team we say we're
going to go from here to there then let
them chart the course because there are
probably many different ways we can
travel to do it and then obviously
continuing to learn and evolve along the
way but um it's a culture change so um i
think we're going to learn our way
through
um our ability to move faster retail
does move fast so i think that helps us
maybe relative to some brands just
inherently
it moves fast we look at ourselves every
day things like that
um but it is also culturally hard when
we talk about speed one and speed two
which i stole from my friend jason
heller who's helping us on some of this
um
some of this agile transformation
we've operated on speed one as brand
builders a lot like i want to go think
about the brief and then we're going to
brief the agency then we're going to
look at a bunch of different options of
how we do it we now need to have a lot
of our team running in what we call
speed 2 which is like okay today what
are we going to do what are the 10
pieces of content that need to go out
okay what worked what didn't work what
the let the machine programmatically
adjust and i think that's the muscle
we're trying to pull in from our
ecommerce and performance marketing
teams and bring that into our brand
marketing teams as well and vice versa
um to kind of start to build that muscle
across the whole
yeah
we call it it's so we call it the and
mentality instead of the or mentality
meaning like let's create both instead
of nitpicking subjectively on
why this should be changed red button
instead of blue button with a bunch of
executives etc the subjectivity needs to
be removed from it quite a bit in order
to have that speed and volume that
you're talking about right now which i
think makes a lot of sense but let's
wrap this up with a bunch of speed round
questions let's get to know mandy
okay pizza or pasta
oh so i am allergic to gluten so like
neither one is great gluten free i'm
gonna say like i'm gonna go to like the
prior choice and i'll take sushi i love
it i love it almond milk or oat milk oat
milk
80s or 90s music 90s
friends are seinfeld
friends
beach or mountains
oh
depends on the time of year but
generally beach
morning person or night person morning
all the way
and last one european vacation or asia
vacation
uh european vacation
okay there we go mandy such a pleasure
seeing you thank you for joining us
thanks
the last that's a wrap
thanks to you both for taking us home
thank you
thank you ryan that was fantastic i love
those speed
we gotta we gotta throw it back to you
one of these times that's what we're
gonna do
like january or february guys let's
figure out our questions we're gonna i
want the audience to
send me some questions that you want us
to ask ryan that's that's the homework
we gotta give you more speed round
questions
before our next episode all right happy
holidays everybody
[Music]
take it easy well so our next episode is
january 20th from noon to one we're
going to be rocking out on all things
tick tock so make sure to join us we're
going to have influencers celebrities
brands all kinds of folks um but until
then happy holidays we've so enjoyed
having you and we'll hope to see you
soon take care